also developing tonight ukraine has
reportedly now recaptured
two key towns we have the latest on the
ground but first the ever struggling joe
biden is doubling down on regime change
in russia
putting the white house in as much
disarray as ever
spinning in circles on every single
front after yet another batch of very
bizarre blunders that are sparking
outrage from american allies all across
the globe we are now at a point where it
is pretty much anyone's guess what the
u.s president actually means or is
actually saying at any given time now
because just when you thought biden
couldn't get any worse well he did and
any off any more of message he did and
any more divorce from reality he is now
joey is finding new ways to stow
confusion and chaos after his own
administration had to clean up three
huge separate remarks over just a matter
of days about putin's bloody invasion
against ukraine now first up last
thursday biden was asked about a
possible chemical weapons attack by
russia telling reporters it would
trigger a response in kind watch this
and to clarify on chemical weapons could
if chemical weapons were used in ukraine
would that trigger a military spot
response from nato
it would
it would trigger a response in kind
a response in kind meaning we'll do the
same thing now shortly after failed
national security adviser jake sullivan
he was forced to clarify biden's remarks
saying it meant that the u.s would quote
respond accordingly well why didn't joe
just say that it only got worse from
there on friday biden appeared to
suggest to us troops that they were
headed to ukraine listen in his own
words
also the average citizen
look at how they're stepping up
look at how they're stepping up
and you're going to see when you're
there and you've sometimes you've been
there you're going to see you're going
to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front of a damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
i'm holding my ground
you will see when you're there again in
comes the white house coms team to clean
up those remarks quote the president has
been clear we are not sending u.s troops
to ukraine and there is no change in
that position you'll see it when you're
there anyway that's not all because on
saturday biden went off script during a
speech this time in poland and called
for again regime change that they had
already cleaned up against putin watch
ukraine will never be a victory for
russia
for free people refused to live in a
world of hopelessness and darkness
we will have a different future a
brighter future rooted in democracy and
principle hope and light
of decency and dignity of freedom and
possibilities
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
make up your mind joey now the media got
kitty at that moment even at that time
attempting to compare him to ronald
reagan and his comments mr gorbachev
tear down this wall anyway saying that
it was similar uh biden's suggesting now
wow he's finally a strong leader but it
was almost immediately in damage control
mode again even biden's own secretary of
state the weak
wink and tony blinken directly
contradicted biden saying regime change
is not on the table yet again and the
white house said in a statement the
president's point was that putin cannot
be allowed to exercise power over his
neighbors or the region
that's not what he said he was not
discussing putin's power in russia or
regime change well then again today he
seemed to message regime change never
stops take a look
do you believe what you said that putin
can't remain in power or do you now
regret saying that because your
government has been trying to walk that
back did your words complicate matters
well you asked three different questions
i'll answer them all number one i'm not
walking anything back
the fact of the matter is i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
toward the way putin is dealing and the
actions of this man
just just
brutality of it
not walking anything back so we're back
now to regime change you can decipher
that if you can you get a gold star but
of course we've all heard what biden
himself said at this point it's such a
complete utter embarrassment it's
humiliating to me we have a president
where even his own staff has no idea
what he will say or what he will mean or
if anyone will even understand it and it
gets even worse as joey doesn't even
think anyone walk back anything
and by the way this was right after
biden doubled down on regime change take
a look at this bizarre exchange with our
own peter ducey earlier today take a
look
are you worried that other leaders in
the world are going to start to doubt
that america is back if some of these
big things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back then let's get him walked
back it made it sound like just in the
last couple days uh it sounded like you
told us troops they were going to
ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about helping train the
troops in that are the the ukrainian
troops that are in poland that's with
the context i sat there with those guys
for a couple hours that's what we talked
about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with
meeting with and talking with the uh
ukrainian troops who were in poland and
when you said a chemical weapon used by
russia would trigger a response in kind
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
why would i tell you you've got to be
silly
the world wants to know the world wants
to know a lot of things i'm not telling
them what the response would be then
russia knows the response
as we just played peter ducey was
completely right he said all three so we
have a president that clearly
is not cognitively up to this job this
is not an opinion this is a fact the
president's cognitive decline is
dangerous the wall street journal today
lays out in a brand new editorial listen
to this quote at what point does joe
biden's verbal incontinence uh start to
become a mortal threat to americans it's
one thing to misidentify your vice
president as the first lady quite
another to call for the ouster of an
autocratic leader of a nation with
nuclear weapons and leaders around the
world they're noticing too allies and
adversaries all are taking notice
president zielinski is reportedly less
than impressed with biden's recent
remarks the french president we're
getting lectured by the french now
macron is telling french media he did
not approve of biden's word choice and
officials in great britain made similar
comments and of course biden's blunders
are just another gift to brutal thug
dictator murderer with blood on his
hands vladimir putin and the russians as
they continue to kill innocent men women
and children all across ukraine with
indiscriminate bombing i've been
consistent since day one
no u.s troops on the ground none
but if you invade a sovereign nation
like putin did and you are killing men
women and children the blood is on the
hands of the invader in this case
vladimir putin that would mean according
to the hannity doctrine you forfeit your
right to lead any country and frankly
you would forfeit your right to even
live joe actually had it right for a
second but only a few minutes and they
walked it away anyway sadly we now have
a president whose words can no longer be
trusted and whose agenda is no longer
clear coherent and comprehensible so
what is the biden doctrine does anybody
know does anyone in the white house know
does joe even know today's monday
and if this wasn't bad enough it's only
going to get weirder and frankly much
creepier look at this moment between
biden a refugee in poland joey talking
about the woman's beautiful eyes her
entire life has been upended and this is
back comes creepy joe take a look
[Music]
joe why didn't you stop it god love you
that would have been perfect this young
woman a refugee her entire life has been
upended and up pops old creepy joe i'll
ask again tonight could biden's
presidency be going any worse than it is
now inflation 40-year high through the
roof gas prices record high after record
high a nationwide food shortage looming
uh the border a catastrophe the
afghanistan withdrawal a deadly debacle
and now we have war in europe and biden
and his own white house can't even keep
the story straight and meanwhile china
they're threatening to invade taiwan i
would expect that's going to happen iran
now has never been closer to getting
nuclear weapons and you got joe biden
sucking up to the muellers of iran and a
deal that would make them rich as hell
and allow even vladimir putin to broker
the deal and help them build a nuclear
facility you got the dictator of
venezuela literally kissing the ass of a
brutal murdering thug dictator begging
opec nations over and over again even
though he gets turned down to produce
more oil all while biden continues to
attack the oil and gas industry right
here at home we have more natural
resources than we could ever use in 200
years look at your screen since joey
entered office biden has taken at least
81 anti-energy actions 81 of them he
killed the keystone pipeline by the way
the premier in alberta said if we
finished it right now we would be
getting 900 000 barrels of oil a day
from canada he's implementing burdensome
emissions regulations cutting off
drilling and auctioning on federal lands
and a whole host of other far left
climate alarmist religious cult policies
new green deal socialism so biden is
failing on policy he's failing on
messaging he's failing internationally
and everywhere in between hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else